- On attendait une hausse
importante des prila consola co.
Elle est encore plus élevée
que prévu : 7,7 % au Canada,
du jamais-vu depuis 1983,
- C'est une situation qui
tous les Québécois.
- Le prix de l'essence
à la pompe a largement
contributout comme le panier d'.
- On regarde beaucoup,
beaucoup les spéciaux, hein,
puis on On n'achète pas trop,
on prépare les menus d'avanc
- Je pense que les gens
font ce qu'ils peuvent.
en même temps que l'inflation.
- Mais le pire pourrait
bientôt être derrière nous,
espère le ministre Girard.
ministre des Finances, Québec
- Normalement, le ement, le emet
de l'inflation est anticipé
autour de mai-juin,
À partir d'ici, on devrait
voir une douce... descente.
- Devant l'inflation galopante,
Québec veut d'aborles consles c.
fie à un sondage
qui est paru ce matin,
les Québécois ont l'air desses s
puis les chèques qu'on envoie
sont les bons moyens.
- Ailleurs dans le monde, chacun
a sa recette pour combattre
la spirale inflationniste.
En Espagne, où l'inflation
atteint 8,7 %, on a choisi
d'abaisser les taxes sures surer
l'énergie et de protéger
les entreprises.
Au Royaume-Uni, on a brisé
un record vieux de 40 ans,
et le gouvernement a annoncé
l'équivalent de 60 milliards
de dollars canadiens
en soutien aux familles.
Chez nos voisins, où le mot
"récession" est sur toutes
les lèvres, le gouvernement
Biden élimine pour trois mois
la taxe ur l'essence,
demande aux gouverneurs
de faire la même chose
et met les compagnies
pétrolières au défi.
Selon les spécialistes,
le déconfinement progressif
de la Chine devrait également
permettre de soulager
l'économie mondiale.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.